last night up a little later than usual
to see the ending of the monday night
football game we got overtime which is
good it was a fun game i wanted it to
continue i was happy that we got some
overtime and uh the saints really
three and two and
they just feel like a far cry chris from
the dominant elite franchise we saw 2017
2018 2019 seasons that all ended in
heartbreaking losses in the postseason
and it's impressive how they've kept
coming back it just feels like this year
they've had a hard time getting that
lawnmower started and we saw it again
last night and they fell behind by 17
and somehow they worked their way back
into it and pulled off the victory yeah
no i mean there's positives right they
scrapped they clawed they hung in there
they found a way to win the football
game you're right but it's not like the
dominant saints team that we feel like
we've seen the last few years to where
we just go
clear cut i don't care how they looked
last night we know they're one of the
best teams in the nfc and right now the
saints
i don't know what to think of them you
know i think there is some positive
certainly i mean there's no doubt about
that but there's just i think more
issues right now than like
glowing great things to talk about hey
it's awesome emmanuel sanders another
week him getting really involved in the
offense i mean drew brees made some
throws down the field so there was there
to whet your appetite but there still
was moments of drew brees where you went
ah that doesn't look great and the same
for the offense in general and then the
defense as we saw lets up too many big
plays so they're a work in progress and
you know the big thing i keep thinking
or just looking at because you see that
yeah they have a problem making big
plays explosive plays it's so much work
all the time
and that's quite honestly where they
miss the best player on their team
that's where you know he's a difference
maker with the fact that michael thomas
can catch a ball six yards over the
middle and it becomes a 12-yard gain and
then he catches a five-yard pass and it
becomes a 14-yard gain and all of those
little yards and plays he does and the
attention he gets it's you can see it
really benefits their team and their
kind of struggle without them
the
saints become the latest team to come
from way behind to win a game we
mentioned last week that the first four
weeks of the season were the first time
ever that a team had come from 16 or
more behind in every week of the season
and now it's five weeks with the saints
pulling it off on monday night the week
began with the buccaneers having a
13-nothing lead over the bears the bears
coming back it's amazing that a
double-digit lead isn't nearly as safe
as it used to be
and i guess the enhanced scoring has
something to do with it right if you're
scoring more points generally a team
that's fallen behind by 16 i just
remember when 17. if you were down 17
right you were done it was over it was
very rare that you could turn it around
and it felt like the chargers were just
going to complete the smothering last
night of the saints when they got up
20-3 so kudos to the saints for figuring
out how to pull it off but they need to
be criticized a little bit for falling
behind and looking just as flat as they
did out of the gate yeah the too many
mistakes on the defensive side of the
ball it's again something we continue to
see to where they they got to simplify
things maybe you know maybe they you
know the one thing that i look at with
the saints at times they're just too
aggressive you know we had this talk
last year a little bit they go for the
kill too much to where you want to go
your defensive line's really good they
can stop the run game almost on their
own we don't have to it doesn't have to
be a you know a negative three yard gain
you know okay they got one yard have an
extra safety back deep so you don't get
burned deep by something like that or
whatever it may be there but mike i
think like the 17 point thing it's
interesting because you know i was
sitting there thinking the same thing
last night of just how often it's
happening right now i gotta think
the fact that there's no fans in the
stadium is a benefit to the offense in
these situations right now because
they're just that that angst that
anxiety in the stadium whether you're
the home team and oh my gosh we're down
17 or if you're on the road and then the
stadium gets ruckus and crazy and
everything like that
then you know that adds to the pressure
of the moment right now it's it's you
know
birds and butterflies it's chirp trip
trip oh this is great i'm i'm out in the
park playing a game with the boys this
is great and that's how the quarterbacks
i feel like are taking it let alone
there's no crowd noise for the pass rush
to get off in these big moments right
now or anything like that to close games
out or make a big play and do that so
i'm glad you brought it there because it
was something that crossed my mind i
think it is a very real thing right now
in the nfl
and think about it how many times in a
given year we're kind of surprised that
a good team gets booed off the field at
halftime right the fans do react yeah
and the fans do get impatient and when
you fall behind by 17 when they think of
all the money they're spending to bring
the wife and the kids and the parking
and the hot dogs and the beer and the
programs and the foam fingers and all
this other stuff and they're not getting
entertained for their money right they
do react viscerally and loudly sometimes
and that's not a factor so we can see
these home teams come back because they
don't feel the crowd has abandoned them
drew brees second time he's led a
comeback of 17 or more points he's 4-0
now against the chargers since he left
the team as a free agent let's hear from
brees after last night's game on how
they scratched and clawed their way back
we were not playing saints football in
the first half you know we were we
missed a lot of opportunities
you know we were bad on third and short
situations that would have sustained
drives you know we made some mistakes in
the kicking game that you know prolonged
drives for them um and just you know
obviously had a turnover that gave them
seven points
so you know at the end of the day we're
down to three and we've made a bunch of
mistakes you know a bunch of
self-inflicted wounds and um i think
second half came out and um man really
dialed in
um
execution you know both in the passing
game and the run game defense came up
with some big stops and obviously we
just scratched and clawed our way back
you know there was a play in the first
half that looked like it would have
popped for a long gain a screen pass to
alvin kamara that he dropped things like
that accumulate and you end up having a
slow first half but they stuck with it
look at the difference chris first half
12 for 22 for brees second half in
overtime 21 for 25 yards from 93 first
half up to 232 touchdown in the second
part of the game interception in the
first part of the game and that
interception and i said this half
jokingly on twitter
i wonder if he had a flashback to when
he was playing for the chargers i mean
that was ugly it was like he was
throwing it to the guy we've seen a few
of those in recent weeks yeah where it's
like the ball it's like who are you
throwing it to because the only guy
there is the guy from the other team
that got it that there's there's no
question we've seen those you know more
aaron throws some bad interceptions from
drew brees and i you know again i i
don't think it's going to totally go
away
as far as those type of interceptions
we're going to see them kind of arise
every now and then you know our producer
matt casey and i we kind of went through
a bunch of throws and things like that a
few weeks ago when they were on sunday
night football the one thing you start
to realize is sometimes those deeper
routes those crossing routes because of
the lack of arm strength and i think we
talked about this
he has to anticipate it a little bit he
has to oh i see the window there
let me lay it in there nice and soft for
my guy to come and get it but you're not
always
guaranteed that guy's gonna be open in
that spot you think is open at that time
you're about to release the ball and i
think that's kind of one of those
instances there where he saw the window
and thought he had the right feel for it
but it closed really quick and he threw
the ball high and everything like that
and it was a bad look that drive before
the the half time right mike that to me
was the change of the game it's like
they got into you know the no huddle and
they really got the ball out of his
hands quick short passes and things like
that i think that filtered over to the
second half and
got them some rhythm and got the defense
of the chargers really trying to stop
those short passes and then they finally
started to hit a few passes behind them
for bigger chunks and things like that
but i looked at that as kind of the
turning point of the football game for
the saints in that offense
and i'm glad you mentioned that
touchdown right before the end of the
half because even though the
the facts and circumstances were
different that's what happened to the
chargers last week when they were up 17
on the buccaneers in the first half it
wasn't allowing a drive it was a mistake
in the backfield and a fumble and then
dominic and sue made a great play to
force the fumble but
two straight weeks now think about it
the chargers come to the east coast they
play the the buccaneers in tampa they're
up 17 they blow it they go to new
orleans to play the saints they're up 17
they blow it they're becoming the afc's
version of the falcons
they are there there's no doubt well
there's you know it's a young team
they don't they're not battle tested
they're they're figuring out how to
manage the game with a young quarterback
and last night i think they over managed
it honestly if you just you know my two
cents of the game would be
hey we saw again for the fourth week in
a row a quarterback who's really special
i mean uh the that this damn kid justin
herbert he's got superstar talent and
you see
i mean just some of the throws he made
the first touchdown pass it's all out
blitz he makes a guy miss runs to the
right throws a rocket in the back of the
endzone to keenan allen touchdown he did
all this last night with only keenan
allen out there for a drive and a half
too let's not forget and really no run
game other than one run that was bro uh
you know broke on the first drive after
that there was nothing else it was all
like well i hope justin herbert hits a
big pass i thought they did the team of
disservice and
uh herbert of the service when they got
up 20-3 they over-managed the game it
was always run on first run on second
hey it's third down do you think you can
throw it in there the saints only run
every defense known to mankind rookie
quarterback tried to figure that out
they never put him in the position of
power they never got into second and
twos or throwing on for first down or
early downs to get ahead of the chains
and things like that to me they almost
played into the hands of letting the
saints come back and that's where um i
think they got to let it loose is what
i'm saying with justin herbert stop
being so careful you you saw every time
he dropped back last night it was damn
good and he delivered and i think they
just got to let it go a little bit more
yeah you can't let yourself get
comfortable you can't let yourself get
conservative no once you build that lead
that's the moment where you got to go
for the jugular that's the moment where
you got to open it up keep doing what
you've been doing turn a 17-point lead
into a 27-point lead and then
you can manage the game through to the
end of the fourth quarter unless you are
the falcons and you know even then a
27-point lead isn't safe but it's not
about the falcons it's about the
chargers today and and let's hear from
justin herbert the quarterback of the
chargers and also coach anthony lynn
reacting to how things ultimately played
out for them in new orleans on monday
night
the third quarter was big we needed to
put up more points than we did and
kind of like you said we got off to a
quick start and um just have to play
consistently all four quarters um and we
unfortunately didn't do that
um but it's a learning process and we're
going to learn from it and um
yeah losing
losing is horrible but i know that we're
going to turn it around this team is
sticking together
and i know that we got the talent to
turn it around
all right anthony lynn not there but let
me tell you something anthony lynn and i
like him a lot i got a ton of respect
for him great guy great coach
it's not sustainable
to lose these games especially this way
what it does to a team what it does to
the people who ultimately make the
decisions about who will or won't coach
the team look at what's happened in
houston then in atlanta and i'm not
saying that anthony lynn is in that
category of guys that has to worry about
being let go during the season but when
the dust settles on the season
when you consider they've got that's
right franchise quarterback a young
franchise quarterback that could make
that job very attractive if this one in
four trend continues and they keep
blowing leads it's it's it's something
that you got to be nervous about if
you're anthony lynn now they go into
their bye week which is probably i don't
know maybe good maybe bad they probably
need a break from blowing these leads
but when they come out of it jaguars at
broncos raiders at dolphins and then the
jets five games that
man you got to go three and two in these
five games
um you got it you got to turn it around
you're not done yet at one and four
because of that seventh seed and other
teams that started strong are going to
fade but they better come out of the
gates strong yeah made it clear
herbert's a guy the rest of the year
they they i think it's critical they
beat the jaguars and there's no reason
to think at this point they shouldn't
beat the jaguars but between the jaguars
broncos games this is a way to get that
you know you get to three and four you
start to feel like you're getting your
head towards water and then they can
deal with the raiders and then all of a
sudden you're four and four but they
they had better make the most of these
next two weeks to figure out how to turn
this around because it's falling apart
even though we're excited by justin
herbert yeah the results aren't there no
they're not and you know it's kind of a
chargers way to lose a game last night
yeah 20-3 it's like we just see it we
saw this every year the last five years
with the chargers except for 2018 right
i mean other than that it just feels
like this is the story of them oh really
the ball hit the goal post on the
game-winning field world shocker i've
never heard of that happening to the
chargers really well and chris yeah to
make the catch by mike williams
where i mean you know and it's just
irrelevant and it shouldn't
the catch he made when he had two guys
land on him ripped his helmet off on the
ground held on to the football
uh and and look the saints made a
mistake having you know anyone
dramatically shorter than mike williams
trying to cover him in that spot but but
it was a great catch great throw great
holding on to the ball and that was a
moment where i mean i know my reaction
was oh bleep yeah the chargers are going
to win this game right i thought so too
i know when he made that play i went uh
oh it's looking good and i think really
again
you know i think it's more evidence and
as we go forward here with them and the
chargers in this conversation because
hey let's let's let's keep it real they
are missing some good players on defense
that are injured and all that i
understand that but the way they're
playing the game right now is really a
disservice to their team
you know their their talent is wide
receivers and tight ends it's not
running backs in an offensive line
nobody talks about the chargers and
talks about josh kelly right now or you
know and or jackson or anything like
that or the offensive line no you know
they got an awesome tight end they got
mike williams they got keenan allen they
got the number six pick of the draft
let's start throwing the football i
don't know where they thought they got
this like you know
false sense of confidence last night
that they were going to be able to just
grind the game away listen the first
drive of the game was great they went
down and then urban made the great
touchdown next drive of the game when
they scored it wasn't good i mean it
wasn't a good drive the the saints
bailed them out like you heard drew
brees there was a roughing the punter on
fourth and 14. then he hit a big pass
they scored the next touchdowns was
set up by what the the interception that
was dr uh returned all the way down to
the three yard line and then there was
no offense until late in the game again
and i i blame that on the chargers and
what they did and their approach from
there to where they really handcuffed
the offense and and didn't play to the
strength of their team right now which
is herbert mike williams and that tight
end
yeah i i agree with you and at play then
in overtime when they were trying to
match the field goal that the saints had
converted the mike williams
uh short of the sticks and look he got
bent backward he got pretzel i thought
he was injured after the game
next gen stats has the animation of the
play and check it out
73.4 chance of converting well the 26.6
came up the winner because they they got
demario davis and lattimore got you did
you know they knew that's the game
that's the game we keep them short of
the sticks that's the game we get to go
home we are home but you get the points
great tackle though sub is a great time
and yeah yeah i was gonna say those are
the two worst throws herbert made all
night the play before that right he
missed the guy over the middle and then
even that throw there even though it was
a good throw i do think if he throws it
a foot out in front of him more
that it's gonna let his momentum take
him he had to kind of turn a little bit
and then lattimore made a phenomenal
tackle i really gotta give him credit
there sorry to cut you off mike
no no it's fine and there's something
that i i need to get clarification from
the league on i sent an email last night
and i hope to get an answer
and um it was cj gardner johnson
who was in the news this week right
because of his altercation with michael
thomas thomas by the way expected back
on wednesday the saints did a good job
of trying to take the steam out of that
because michael thomas you don't want it
to linger you want to take his medicine
be okay with it come back and basically
act like it never happened and they've
done a good job of not making it a huge
deal it's pretty big deal with all the
other stuff going on think about it if
there weren't all these other things
happening in the nfl right now primarily
with pandemic the thomas thing would
have been gigantic news but uh gardner
johnson
immediately after that play ended
whips his helmet off throws and every
time i see that i think of the duane
rudd play and i know it was a long time
ago but it hasn't happened since then
yeah now dwayne rudd threw his helmet
off during what was the final play of a
game supposedly but it was during the
play when he believed that the browns
had beaten the chiefs it was game over
they throw the flag the browns get 15
yards on time down field goal win the
game go home
i'm looking at the rule
it's unsportsmanlike conduct for removal
of a helmet by a player in the field of
play or the end zone during a
celebration or demonstration or during a
confrontation with a game official or
any other player so he was celebrating
the fact that they stopped mike williams
and we've seen this happen it happened
earlier this year when the clock hit
zero and the game's over right i don't
know how it applies in a situation like
this
where yeah the game's over but simply
because i mean there's still time on the
clock this is a weird thing right and
yeah and what what what rules don't get
enforced when the game's over like if
you walk up to the quarterback at the
end of that play and deck him
is it just oh well the game's over i i i
need clarification there because i'm
confused and i figure if i'm confused
others are confused so let's just clear
this up and figure out what it really is
because even though it's a ticky tack
kind of thing that makes people upset
when it happens because it really has
nothing to do with the game it's a rule
that's on the books you either enforce
it or you don't when do you enforce it
when do you not enforce it and i'm just
trying to to figure that out because
anytime that happens i it's one of those
oh i know you're all you're all over it
oh we know we know
but is it but but when you had a game
taken away from the browns even though
it was 18 years ago i get you you wonder
what what the hell the rule is and when
it works and when it doesn't work and
and either get rid of the rule or apply
the rule that's what always bothers me
there's so many rules on the books they
don't apply well then get rid of the
rules yeah because it confuses people
who are trying to understand what the
game is and what the game isn't chris
well yeah you're you're uh like you know
inspector gadget for these moments first
of all you always find them you're very
good at that
but you're right i know
i think you're right though i think it's
one of those rules where the nfl just
said like let's not really enforce that
that's not really let's not go there
again and you're probably right they
need to just wipe it off the books or
get it over with there i don't know how
that goes you know as soon as he's down
and doesn't make the first down the game
is over so it's a weird spot but you're
right you bring up good questions as far
as if you got in the quarterback's face
and you know punched him or decked him
did we extend the game i don't know how
that goes you know we've never had too
many scenarios like that
my dad and ronnie lot tried to figure
that out one year in a monday night
football game where they got in a fight
after the game but
i i can't think of any circumstances or
you know uh instances that that it did
happen that i can you know recall
what the hell is your dad doing messing
with ronnie lott because well you you uh
the story is you know jim burt who
played on the giants for all those years
he went to san francisco and basically
told the defense that you know to get
them going that my dad had no respect
for the 49ers defense and he didn't
think they were all that great and all
that and you know that's what
competitors do ronnie lott took it
personal he didn't really care if it was
the truth or not he wanted to believe it
[Laughter]
they got each other's face that's all
there was to it
there's a cluster now at the top of the
nfc south
the buccaneers three and two the saints
three and two
the panthers three and two man if you
just show me the standings crazy three
and two three and two three and two oh
and five i'd assume the panthers are on
five and i just said hey watch out for
the falcons right but it's the falcons
that are winless and the panthers right
in the mix the only one of those teams
they played above them is the buccaneers
they lost week two so that means three
more games against the teams they're
currently tied with and you know for as
flat as the saints have looked for as as
streaky as the buccaneers are as they
continue to get accustomed to tom brady
being their quarterback yeah the
panthers i i am so i know this is about
last night but you know we're talking
about the division the panthers are are
impressive
and they're very much alive and they got
to be feeling very good this is kind of
like that the season is kind of like
that game where you let the inferior
team hang around long enough that it
finally says screw it we're just going
to take it you don't want to let the
panthers hang around very long or they
are just going to say screw it we're
going to take this thing no i mean and
like you said there you know you said
yesterday they're two losses they could
have easily won they could have beat the
raiders week one you know and then the
buccaneers lost that was there to be had
too they made a lot of mistakes on that
game to where the game was still in the
balance and kind of let tampa take over
i i like a lot of what i see from
carolina they are ex you know fun and
exciting it's a cool story um
i i'm still though
holding out hope for the saints like the
saints i'm not giving up on them yet i'm
not i still think there's too many
positives on this football team i think
the defense will get it figured out this
is what they do
you know i don't know what it is they're
a little crazy there in new orleans and
i mean that in a good way as coaches but
every year it just seems like they start
out they got to figure out what they're
going to do they're over aggressive on
defense they miscommunicate mess things
up and then they kind of figure out how
and what they want to do to simplify it
or make it better and i do think when
michael thomas gets back that changes
their football team i really do i agree
with you so yeah and then you know what
yeah i was just saying are you giving up
on the bucks yet what do you think about
them i mean i still think the bucks are
a team to watch out for i know they
believe that came to me the other night
too
i think they'll be fine i think they'll
be in it i just think that
you may end up forfeiting the division
of the panthers if you don't
knock them out and make it saints bucks
fairly soon uh we haven't made our
perfunctory taste some hill
mention and and look he i i they still
aren't using them as much as they should
for what they're paying him and as we
said within the past couple of weeks
either make him your backup quarterback
and never put him on the field or
embrace the fact that you have this
weapon you can use and let him get into
the rhythm and flow of the game don't
use him in little spots you know he fell
down on what could have been a touchdown
catch he was targeted twice last night
he threw a pass that was off the mark
and it kind of looked like the receiver
fell down as well but he had that
touchdown run that just proves to you
what he can do he's got a gear when he
gets a chance to get his first couple
steps almost like derrick henry he takes
a couple steps to get there but man once
he gets there
you you would be wise to get the hell
out of the way that's right you couldn't
pay me enough money to get in front of
him when he goes starts going downhill i
mean he is just rocked up and he is
explosive and he's he's not shying away
from any contact i mean it's full speed
into people who are running at him full
speed you're right you know i i mean
just as a fan and a guy who likes to
watch him and i like sean payton and how
he calls the game and coaches his team
i'd like to see them get the ball in his
hands a little bit more uh i don't know
where they are with that either you're
right but he is a difference maker when
he does touch the ball now he did fumble
you know the two weeks prior to this
maybe that you know makes him a little
gun shy i don't know but it is very hard
to your point to get in the flow of the
game with how he plays and what they do
with him you know maybe they need to
find a few more ways to cheat or give
him the ball when he is that h-back
tight end and just be a little more
conscious of that to then when he does
have to play quarterback and have a
design run it's not such a long time and
between him touching the ball or feeling
as he's a part of the offense so uh sean
payton will figure it out i think you
and i both are very very big fans of him
and they're they're they'll figure out
that formula that works best
one thing that i noticed last night that
i don't think they'd been doing usually
when hill lines up at quarterback drew
brees is still on the field at least
twice last night brees was off the field
all together and they were fairly
important moments in there they were
and you just wonder is that going to be
a trend now was that just a little a
little test to see how breeze handled it
and and also keep in mind we haven't
mentioned this yet but brees got
pretzeled up and he was limping around
for a little bit and that's one of those
where i'm gonna be interested to see
their injury report on wednesday and see
if he's limited in practice with an
ankle injury or something like that
because i think the adrenaline took over
but it looked like he was banged up a
little bit and the touchdown pass he
threw a few plays later may have gone a
long way toward healing it at least for
the remainder of the game but that may
be one of those when you're 41 years old
and you're rolling out of bed the next
morning you're going to feel it a lot
more than you felt it down the stretch
of the game i i agree i mean he looked
like he was laboring a little bit he got
you know had that one throw where he
threw it in the right somebody came in
and hit his legs i mean there was a few
moments during the game where i felt
like he was a little shook up and just
sucking it up and and playing through it
to where i i'm with you i'll be
interested to see when the the injury
report comes out on wednesday just to
see if he's on there or how good he
feels because it it could be that that
like that one he kind of got his leg
stuck and i thought oh man he might have
a little bit of a high ankle sprain here
and like you're saying the adrenaline
the game you're warm you're going you
know you'll feel okay for now but yes he
might wake up this morning and go oh
crap man i got a you know a
significantly sprained ankle here we'll
see where we go but uh drew brees you
know even for his struggles and
everything he does
you know the first half looking ugly he
just stays the course keeps executing
that offense and he was surgical from
that last drive of the second half for
the rest of the game on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports